hallo und herzlich willkommen zurück auf
einem kanal in diesem video teile ich
mein allerliebstes rezept zum
fermentieren mit dir nämlich werden wir
in diesem video tomaten fermentieren
genauer gesagt cherrytomaten sie werden
da vier unterschiedliche varianten von
diesem rezept erstellen da kannst du dir
eine zwei oder auch alle vier rauspicken
je nachdem ob du es lieber scharf mag
dort thymian stehst oder auch knoblauch
kannst du dir da aussuchen was dir zu
sagt ich habe eigentlich immer den
ganzen sommer über und auch im herbst
immer mehrere gläser von diesen
fermentierten tomaten bei mir zu hause
denn das ist wirklich ein super leckeres
rezept die werden so ein bisschen witz
liegt die tomaten wenn man definiert wie
werden wieso kleine sternenexplosionen
in deinem mund und viele leute sind ja
immer sehr skeptisch was fermentierte
sachen angeht weil sie das einfach nicht
kennen und wir hatten schon so oft
besucht dem ich dann diese tomaten auf
benötigt hat der mir dann einfach alle
gläser leer gefuttert hat weil die durch
die bank weg alle leute so gefeiert
haben diese tomaten also eine absolute
empfehlung gerade wenn du noch nie
fermentiert hast um damit mal anzufangen
und mal auszuprobieren wie abgefallen
lecker und unglaublich vielfältig
fermentierte gemüse denn überhaupt
schmecken können
[Musik]
implementieren ist es ganz wichtig dass
du erst mal deine gläser sauber machst
kannst du dir ganz normale schraubgläser
verwenden zum beispiel den honig glas da
passt natürlich nicht so viel rein oder
auch größere gleise es gibt ja auch
diese band ihr auf sätze die man kaufen
kann die man auf diese klausel drauf
machen kann ich habe auch welche aber
ehrlich gesagt benutze ich die
eigentlich nie weil ich da keinen großen
unterschied sehe und ich da die meisten
von euch die wäsche eigentlich nicht
haben zu hause habe ich dir jetzt
einfach mal weggelassen das braucht ihr
überhaupt nicht dass ich da nicht über
den tisch
es gibt so viele teure fermentiert
zubehör sachen die man kaufen kann
gerade im internet man braucht es nicht
man kann mit den einfachsten techniken
fermentieren das ist ja auch eine uralte
methode um gemüse haltbar zu machen
früher hatten die auch nicht so silikon
mädchen für ihre gläser was ich ganz
praktisch finde sind solche fermentieren
gewichte aber ich zeige euch auch gleich
wie er das anstellen könnt wenn ihr die
nicht zu hause habt wenn ihr die wahl
habt nehmt lieber solche mit solchen
griffen dran
wie kann man nämlich hinterher viel
leichter aus dem glas wieder rausheben
als wenn die keine gewichte haben
aber wie gesagt das kann sie auch
wunderbar improvisieren ihr braucht zum
fermentieren wirklich gar kein zubehör
das sich schon zu hause habt also fangen
wir an wir waschen die gläser dann
spüren wir die mit kochendem wasser aus
so dass da keine bakterien die und
nachher die erste form machen können
oder eben spaß an unseren tomaten mehr
in dem glas rum bräuchen und leuchten
auch die decke koche ich immer mit
heißem wasser ab da wird da nichts mehr
dran ist das ist einfach ja kein
unbedingt notwendiger schritt aber es
hilft ungemein um eine größere
erfolgsquote zu haben beim fermentieren
dann setzt sich auch eine salzlauge an
da könnt ihr mal eure gläser alle mit
wasser voll machen und dann in eine
große schüssel kippen das wasser dann
müsst ihr euch merken wie viel wasser
das war und wenn
gebt ihr pro liter wasser einfach
zweieinhalb esslöffel salz mit dazu dann
habt ihr den richtigen salzgehalt für
dieses rezept so dass die tomaten
daneben auch gut haltbar sind und dass
da ein gutes klima in eurem gläsern
herrscht damit sich die
milchsäurebakterien da gut ausbreiten
können die sitze schon auf dem gemüse
selber drauf also wenn das nicht dreckig
ist dann am besten nicht waschen das
gemüse so spürt ihr die in den abschluss
wenn das traffic ist heute ist entweder
abbürsten wenn man es mal wäscht ist es
auch nicht schlimm da überleben in der
regel eigentlich noch genug
milchsäurebakterien so dass das kein
problem ist aber wenn man eben nicht
unbedingt was muss dann lass das lieber
dann habt ihr mehr von eurem guten
kleinen moment ihre helfer stehen in
eurem glas die euch dann helfen diese
leckeren tomaten umzusetzen das ist ja
eigentlich eine form der verrottung für
eine kontrollierte war ebenso zu sein
wieder stattfindet hat sich nicht so
lecker ist es aber und wenn man mal
darüber nachdenkt dann ist die
fermentation in unserem alltag und in
unserem unseren lebensmitteln ja
allgegenwärtig käse joghurt wir sind ja
auch alles fermentierte lebensmittel
sogar sauerteigbrot im rezept findet ihr
übrigens auf meinem blog wenn ihr das
mal ausprobieren wollt das sind alles
fermentierte lebensmittel und das hier
ist dann auch überhaupt nicht eklig wenn
man das dann ist also ist herzlich immer
irgendwie abschrecken dann aber ist es
überhaupt nicht ich koche die salzlake
die ich zum fermentieren verwende auch
gerne ab deswegen ist das auch einer der
ersten schritte die einmal erhitzen dass
sie schön blöd man kann natürlich auch
einfach kochen das wasser verwenden mit
dem man die salzlager ansetzt dann
abkühlen lassen so dass die
milchsäurebakterien die auf den tomaten
braucht sind jetzt nicht toth gekocht
werden wenn man da einfach heißes wasser
übergießt also die salzlake ganz wichtig
unbedingt abkühlen lassen auf
zimmertemperatur oder so weit dass sie
zumindest lauwarm ist damit unseren
kleinen fleißigen milchsäurebakterien
nichts passiert dann die tomaten an
liebsten einfach einmal mit einem
zahnstocher fünfmal in jede tomate reihe
fixen es ist übrigens ganz klug tomaten
zu verwenden die ein bisschen unruhig
sind weil sie dann später nicht so ganz
arg schrumpelig und wabbelig werden also
wenn du noch ein paar tomaten an deinen
sträuchern hast die vielleicht noch ein
bisschen hart sind dann sind das die
perfekten kandidaten für dieses rezept
dann packt ihr eure zutaten in die
gläser ich habe da ein glas mit chili
und thymian voll gepackt und dann mit
tomaten aufgefüllt da die salzlager
drauf und mit einem gewicht so
beschweren dass alle teile unter wasser
gedrückt werden das ist ganz wichtig
weil sobald auch nur ein viertel seines
gemüses an die luft kommt kann sich der
schimmel bilden und dieses gewicht das
verhindert eben das da schimmel
überhaupt angreifen kann an dein gemüse
solange alles unter der lage ist
brauchst du dir wegen stehen wir
überhaupt keine sorgen zu machen wenn du
sie ein bisschen schärfer magst dann
kannst du die chili natürlich auch
halbieren oder in kleine ringe schneiden
dann würde ich aber die kerne entfernen
einfach weil die auftreiben können die
kriegt man mit dem gewicht auf nicht so
gut beschwert und dann wäre es ärgerlich
wenn sich deswegen schimmel in einem
glas bildet die nächste variante ist
hier einfach ein glas tomaten mit
rosmarin da einfach dem zweig mit ins
glas geben so dass er auch unter der
lage ist wenn man das ganze dann
beschwert und mit tomaten auffüllen ihr
müsst mit den kräutern ein bisschen
vorsichtig sein denn die werden
sehr intensiv auf die tomaten abfärben
in anführungszeichen das wird sehr stark
nach rosmarin schmecken am ende wenn ihr
das lieber ein bisschen dezenter haben
wollt dann gebt lieber ein bisschen
weniger kräuter mit ins glas als allzu
viel in das könnte ein bisschen overkill
sein ich verwende am liebsten immer
ganze zweige
denn wenn man die kräuter klein hacken
können die wie bei den chilis auch
einfach auftreiben und an die oberfläche
schwimmen und wenn man die zweige
einfach mit ins glas gibt dann ist das
gesichert dann kann da nicht auftreiben
und das ganze kann nicht verschwimmen
für die dritte variante habe ich jetzt
einfach mal thymian mit ins glas gepackt
übrigens mein absolutes lieblings kraut
ich könnte mich da rein legen
und da zeige ich euch jetzt mal wie das
ist wenn man zb kein film and ihr
gewicht hat dafür habe ich jetzt einfach
mal zwei steine gesucht für die letzten
beiden gelehrter die ungefähr so groß
sind wie die öffnung des glases also die
da gut reinpassen die ziemlich flach
sind und die habe ich gut gewaschen und
auch abgekocht und die verwende ich
jetzt einfach als gewicht das
funktioniert wunderbar in dem fall weil
die steine jetzt aber das glas nicht
ganz ausfüllen und da schon noch sachen
auftreiben könnten habe ich ein kurbad
in meinem garten geerntet und klein
geschnitten so dass das die tomaten
erstmal abdeckt das kommt da wie eine
schutzmarke drüber damit nicht
auftreiben kann und darauf trage ich
dann das gesicht und da auch immer
darauf achten dass dann auch das kurbad
von der lage bedeckt ist im zweifel
einfach noch mal ein bisschen mehr makel
einfüllen
es ist okay wenn das gewicht oben
rausschaut aber eben keine organischen
teile also keine tomaten kräuter chili
oder kohlblätter die sollten alle immer
von der lage bedeckt seien und daher
habe ich noch die letzte variante
das ist meine lieblings variante muss
ich ganz ehrlich sagen da habe ich
basilikum und knoblauch unten mit ins
glas gepackt die knoblauchzehen habe ich
in dem fall einfach nur geschält man
kann natürlich auch noch ein bisschen
zerkleinern
aber eben nicht zu verstecken
denn weil sie dann wieder auftreiben
können an die oberfläche und die packe
ich einfach mit unten ins glas damit sie
auch von den tomaten gut beschwert sind
und möglichst nicht auftreiben können
denn die basilikumblätter sind ja
relativ 1
und die könnten sich dann nach oben
mogeln und uns ärger machen
das habe ich auch wieder mit einem cool
blatt abgedeckt und dann ein stein
darauf gelegt das funktioniert genauso
wie mit diesen teuren überteuerten muss
man ehrlich gesagt sagen das ist ja
einfach nur ein stück glas wie wir
diesen gewichten da könnt ihr also
wunderbar improvisieren lasst euch da
nicht über den tisch ziehen
ihr braucht keine fermentiert selbst für
100 euro kaufen um euer eigenes gemüse
zu fermentieren keine sorge wenn die
lage ein bisschen trüb wird das fängt
bei meinen gläsern jetzt auch schon an
ich hab das gestern oder vorgestern
vorgestern habe ich die angesetzt und
das fängt jetzt an ein bisschen trübt zu
werden und das ist gar kein problem das
heißt einfach nur dass die
milchsäurebakterien in deinem ferment
richtig gut arbeiten das ist also ein
gutes zeichen
es kann auch mal vorkommen dass sich auf
deinen gläsern kam hilfe bildet das ist
eine dünne weiße schicht an der
oberfläche die aber nicht pelzig ist wie
bei schimmel sondern einfach fertig und
bisschen so wie elefanten haut aussieht
also es auch kein problem das ist
einfach ein hefepilz der sich manchmal
in verwenden bildet ist auch sehr gesund
sagt man
den kannst du einfach abschätzen und weg
gießen es kann sein dass er dann immer
mal wieder kommt wenn dein glas damit
denn infiziert ist aber das ist
überhaupt kein problem den auch zu essen
du kannst denn auch drauf lassen oder
einfach abspielen wenn du deine gemüse
dann aus der lake and nimmst du musst du
dir dann gar keine sorgen machen einfach
genau hinschauen das ist kein schimmel
ist schimmel ist wie gesagt tätig und
kam hefe ist einfach diese faltige haut
die aber keine
keine fans sondern sie sind nicht so
kühl schicken will das kann man schon
ganz gut unterscheiden wenn das ganze
schimmel sollte weil vielleicht doch mal
irgendwas aufgetrieben ist an die
oberfläche dann aber weg damit es gibt
leute die sagen ja
da brauche ich den schimmel haut raus
und es trotzdem aber da würde ich nie
machen beim fehlen und das würde ich
wirklich lassen wenn ihr vielleicht auch
noch andere gemüse fermentieren volt
außer tomaten dann habe ich für euch
eine checkliste erstellen mit allen
schritten die man seit fermentieren
beachten sollte damit es eben nicht
schimmelt dann wird es am ende auch
lecker schmeckt hier könnt ihr euch
gerne herunterladen der link ist unten
in der video beschreibung dies kostenlos
habe ich einfach für euch erstellt so
als kleine hilfestellung und übersicht
ich habe mir diese checkliste am anfang
als ich mit dem ganzen technik mir
angefangen habe mit dem haltbarmachen
unserer ernte habe ich mir die selber
erstellt und in meinem schrank gehängt
so dass sich die immer parat hatte und
wusste dass ich an alle schritte denke
und nichts falsch machen fermentieren
dann ist es ja super ärgerlich wenn man
gerade selber angebaute lebensmittel
haltbar machen möchte und dann macht man
irgendetwas falsch und wenn es
ungleichheit ist das reicht oft schon
aus und das ganze vergammelt einen das
ist so ärgerlich gerade wenn man dann
auch noch die ganze zeit rein gesteckt
hat um das ganze auch zu verarbeiten das
muss sich sein deswegen ladet euch die
gerne herunter und da unten findet ihr
meine vorratskammer tue wenn ihr wissen
wollt wie so eine selbstversorger
vorratskammer aussieht schaut gerne da
unten rein ansonsten sehen sie jetzt
nächsten samstag wieder ich freue mich
auf euch bis dann